Okay, this is why I hate all men joking
I don't but now that I've got your attention all lies up here,
1 million people here they've been ordered to evacuate
I place has ordered eastern rougher to evacuate
I think that's around 100,000 people and where are they supposed to go?
These people already living in camps,
these are people many of whom have already been evacuated.
The UN has said they do not support this kind of ground invasion
and yet I place is going ahead with it anyway
so this isn't an evacuation
this is a G side Yesterday 25 homes were bombed
25 people were unalived
you gonna come and do that just hours after ordering people to leave?
To add to that,
this is really near where there are crucial aid entry points
so this is effectively blocking that aid that much needed aid.
Al Jazeera has also been banned in that whole region
at being one of the last independent media sources
because G side requires propaganda and brainwashing to be successful.
1984 or 2,024 there are so many ways you can help.
This is the one I'll drop the link below that I've been helping with
and we've come a really long way
if you can please do donate
if you can't please share
please like please press all the buttons
please just don't look away at this time
just stay engaged with it
keep showing up. Thank you.